it's been a while since workers in
Nigeria have been on the streets to
protest
but petrol prices have soared along with
other costs after government scrapped
fuel subsidies in May
Trade union leaders say earnings no
longer keep up with inflation
they want a reversal of government
policies
the demands is that the federal
government
all the sufferings
of Nigerians
workers and other Nigerians and their
masses through their economic policies
in order that driving the people to the
bricks
people like Muhammad an official of a
local pensioners union military are
really suffering it's just wickedness in
this country that they are still paying
pension at three thousand
three thousand that cannot cannot that
cannot buy you cook anywhere
that's about four US dollars a month
similar protests were also held in the
commercial Capital Lagos and elsewhere
in the capital protests were largely
peaceful
until demonstrators reach the Parliament
building to find the gates locked
after a brief standoff they brought it
down despite the heavy presence of armed
security personnel
once inside Union chanted their demands
and leaders gave speeches before
presenting their complaints to senators
at his inauguration in May president
Bola Ahmed tinubu announced an end to
Nigeria's costly field subsidy program
since then the cost of petrol and other
Goods have soared for Nigeria's 215
million population in addition to the
Fallout of the fuel subsidy the local
currency also lost nearly a third of its
value against the U.S dollar when the
government plotted the naira in June
that has added two people struggles here
in Nigeria as the cost of goods and
services have increased sharply
ahead of Wednesday's plan demonstrations
government leaders announced various
measures to cushion the effects of the
high cost of living for Nigerians
but the unions are unimpressed
members of parliament have offered to
mediate
we are going to walk in between that and
come with the amicable solution to the
problem that you are facing do we have a
time frame we are one week for us our
involvement
is unclear whether politicians will be
able to meet those demands union leaders
say if they fail worker strikes will
cause the country to grind to a hold how
many degrees Al Jazeera